jackson good afternoon
uh how can dr d and i help man
hey guys my name is jack jackson i'm 16
and i'm considering selling my truck i
have a 2019 chevy colorado that is worth
about 23-24 grand
and i owe 6 500 on it so i'm considering
selling it
paying off the loan and using what's
left by a different truck
my dad however says i should stick with
it because this truck will be able to
last me through college
and he worries the truck i would be able
to buy a wall last name
jackson
i know what you're about to say yeah i'm
trying he's a young man so i'm just
trying you know
okay let me rewind hey all right jackson
so help me understand
um how are you 16 years old and you have
a trust so i'm guessing this truck is in
your dad's name
uh yes it is in my dad's name okay cool
so the truck is in your dad's name
and you all owe 6 500 on the truck
right now right and you're saying it's
worth
24 000.
right somewhere around that my dad gave
me
about 18 to put on it but he convinced
me to be able to get a nicer truck to go
above that 18
and buy a better truck and then he would
help me get a loan and i would
pay to pay it back sir are you paying
back to your dad is that what you owe
the money to
um well technically it's an actual loan
through a bank
but it's in his name but it's like
drifting out of my account and that kind
of stuff
okay sorry so anthony you can correct me
if i'm wrong this
this sounds like an a
dollar and cents question wrapped up in
a real messy year 16 year old kid
living in your dad's house question and
the easy thing if you were 25 and
calling us we would tell you
sell the truck man you're going to have
6 500 and that's an easy no-brainer
the challenge you're going to have is
being a 16-year-old kid in your dad's
house
and dad's the one paying this i mean
that's the one that's got his name on
this loan
um you're helping pay for it and things
are a little more complex than that so
if you went and just sold this truck
this afternoon
what would he say to you would he be
angry with you he can't sell it it's in
his dad's name
well that well i've already talked with
him and
i think he's okay with it he sees where
i'm coming from
and i think he's okay with it he just
like i said he says you know if you'll
keep this one it'll last you through
like
he says it'll westminster law school
that's what i hope to do
go to college and then law school
cool so here's my thing for you jackson
you have two options
how much money do you have in a savings
account saved
right now um not a lot
uh six seven hundred dollars something
like that seven hundred dollars
okay cool um right now if the car is
worth twenty four
thousand dollars that means you have
about seventeen thousand seventeen
thousand five hundred dollars in equity
in the car
if you were my son well viewers if you
were my son we would have never
purchased a car we would have never took
out the loan but right now
if you were my son in a situation i'd
like son i get you i'm taking that
seventeen thousand five hundred dollars
in equity
i'm gonna go buy me a ten thousand
dollar max truck
i'm gonna put that seventy five hundred
dollars in the savings account and i'm
gonna cash flow my college
i may even buy like a seventy five
hundred dollar truck i may even just say
you know i'm gonna go buy a six thousand
dollar honda
um i get it yeah i see you're in
birmingham trucks are the thing
out there especially trust us things
period so i i understand it
or or you can have honest conversation
with your dad and say look
i don't want any debt um
either we need to pay off the car but i
don't want any debt attached to me going
into college
but being 16 i like the fact that you
having a 10 000
truck boom paid for 7 500 sitting or six
thousand dollars sitting in your savings
account
to go towards college uh that's my
opinion uh
but i would i would love to have a
conversation with your father tell them
you know uh follow me on instagram
follow me on youtube
uh so we can have a conversation uh
because
i i have a problem with parents
not not teaching their kids everything
and giving them
all the options why do we only push
get into debt take out student loans get
a car loan
get a credit card so you can establish a
credit score like i
really wish someone would have taught me
when i was in high school
hey here's another option you can go to
debt free option
and teach me everything on that side you
know we have so many classes which i
won't name on air
that teach you how to how to protect
yourself
if you decide to go down one certain
road but when it comes to money we don't
teach our young people
how to protect themselves when they go
down the financial road right we say hey
listen
go hurt yourself go rack up all this
debt go do all this stuff
and then boom now you're wondering why
80 percent of the people in america
are living paycheck to paycheck what
strengths they had gotten well and i
think it starts with
uh i think it starts from a place of
love i can imagine
i i'm a dad i want my kid to have the
best
i want him to be safe i have all these
imaginary challenges he's going to have
and then man then i've got 18 thousand
dollars i'm going to put on the table
for him
and then i'm going to teach him what i
think is the right thing which i'm going
to teach him about credit i'm going to
teach him about
paying your debts all these things that
we have attached to quote-unquote
normal way of living yeah and i think
i'm doing them a favor yeah i think i'm
doing him a favor
right but i'm not you know right and so
i want to come at parents and say
i know you love your kids right i know
you've saved up
money and you want to help them out help
them out in a
totally radical new way which is to be
beholden to
nobody ever you know i was oh so funny
you said that
uh when i was on vacation for my
birthday i went out and played golf with
my dad
and he said something to me that just
really struck a chord with me that
really helped me understand why my
father
didn't teach me the things that i wish i
knew today about money
and he said son i grew up with 18
siblings
okay he's number 16 out of 18 siblings
you know my grandmother and all of my
aunts and uncles
um lived with the man back time back in
those days and they
picked cotton and so back then having
money
meant that you had at least two three
hundred dollars in your
in your name it wasn't you had a big fat
savings it
it wasn't uh that you were investing
into your future no it just means you
had a roof over your head
and you had a deep decent transportation
and
decent transportation to them was a bus
ticket and then
you were eating and so when i when i
heard my dad my dad something
said something to me while i was on the
golf course i mean it was part
it was a whole number three it's a par
three he was about to swing and he said
he looked at me said son
today i'm i'm wealthy i was like
you know what yo i'm wealthy because if
my
if my mother was alive today that what i
have
right now is a whole lot of money to my
mom
he was like so i couldn't teach you what
you have today
because i was never exposed to what you
have today
he said i taught you what i knew because
i loved you and so when you
said that that sparked something into me
that you're right
parents are doing it out of love and
which is why i'm hoping that every
parent hear us today
we're giving you the right information
the wisdom and the knowledge
so that you can pass down this
information to the kids who you love
that's right that's right and most of us
are parenting the best way we know how
with the tools we have in our bag
and we were parented that way our
parents loved us
and they had most of us not everybody
but most of us and they tried to parent
us with the best tools they had in their
bag
and it's just trying to give them some
more tools and say hey there is another
way yeah
there's another way i'm curious dr d
you have some kids i don't what is one
thing you would tell
me in america when it comes to your kids
that you wish you knew
before having kids um
i wish that i had known that
the um the way to make a
kid feel anchored in is to
show them not tell them i thought that
the key to being a good parent was
having all the right answers and the key
to being a good parent was telling them
all the right things
and i the the beautiful thing about
going back to college as an old person
was i had to go be an intern again
and i worked for a psychologist who was
way younger than me and he
we worked with traumatized abused
children and
for a short summer and he told me
something stuck with me forever which
was
john kids don't listen to you they watch
you yeah if you want your son to treat
women right
treat your wife right if you want your
daughter to be respectful to the people
in your home
you be respectful to people in your home
and that changed everything for me wow